there's a kind of expectation these days
that if it's imax it's going to be a
bunch of explosions and a lot of special
effects this is a movie that really was
made in a very handmade almost analog
way shooting on celluloid doing a lot of
the effects practically and instead of
explosions and monsters were showing
dance numbers and Technicolor pallets
and sweeping strings recorded the
old-fashioned way with real musicians in
a room it's a kind of old Hollywood
approach to big screen movie making that
I love that we don't see that much of
anymore so I love giving it the kind of
emphasis that imax does the movie has
this incredible kind of width to it and
the color is so extreme and beautiful I
can't imagine you know not seeing that's
on a big screen because it just is such
a rich experience and then in terms of
hearing it I mean as musical with the
kind of scoring a 90 piece orchestra
playing all these songs I think it
sounds like a pretty cool way to see a
movie that was really made for theaters
in the ultimate theater setting one of
the things I was really happy with was
the extent to which the image held up on
imax the grain the texture the focus
really sort of sustained and held up in
a very beautiful way this film was made
to be seen on a big screen it was made
to be a real cinematic experience you
know it's one of the main things Damien
talked to me about that he wanted to
make a film at you you would have to see
in the theater with people i think i
might sounds like the most exciting
version of them I wanted every moment of
this movie to feel epic you know I
wanted it to feel like a big screen epic
about everyday life you know how you
take a story of ordinary people in a
real-life city often shooting real
locations that aren't even the most
glamorous locations in the city but
invest them with the same kind of
grandeur and urgency that you expect
from the giant blockbuster or an epic
you know widescreen spectacular or an
old-fashioned musical for that
and one lovely thing about imax is that
it kind of does a lot of that lifting
for you it does elevate even the
smallest moments and also just it does
feel like the right marriage you know if
material and format this does feel like
a movie that is well served by imax and
i really wanted the movie to arc and
back to some of those fifties sixties
Roadshow movies so you had to see on a
big screen and in some ways I think I
max is kind of the the modern-day
equivalent of that
[Music]